bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 15
septembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'information tout de suite nous
commençons avec les titres de votre
actualité locale
comment sont formés les animateurs qui
interviennent en primaire lors des temps
d'activités scolaires
reportage à l'encan lors d'une session
dédiée à la création d'une web radio
l'association solidarités nouvelles face
au chômage fête ses 30 ans à cette
occasion elle a participé à la création
d'une pièce de théâtre mettant en scène
le quotidien des demandeurs d'emploi des
comédiens joueront sur scène anecdotes
et histoires vraies à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 1 et le modem
fait sa rentrée pas encore d'alliances
avec les républicains pour les
régionales en île de france le modem
pourrait se présenter seul face aux
électeurs en attendant dans les yvelines
la campagne sur le terrain se poursuit
avec des conférences et des rencontres
et pour parler des 30 ans de
l'association solidarités nouvelles face
au chômage nous recevons deux invités il
faisait le piège bonsoir à vous et
hélène cazalis alors is delpech vous
êtes responsable de l'association au
sein de l'antenne de saint quentin en
yvelines et lemm cazalis vous êtes
responsable de la communication de
l'association nous reviendrons avec vous
deux sur les trente ans justement de
l'association dans quelques instants
et ce mardi matin c'est l'info
principale de ce jour pierre bédier le
président du conseil départemental a été
élu président de l'opi voix le pi voix
et je le rappelle un bailleur social qui
gère 50 mille logements dans les
yvelines l'essonne et le val d'oise et
emploie près d'un millier de personnes
pierre bédier a déjà occupé cette
fonction entre 1994 et 2005
il a souligné l'importance de l'enjeu
qu'est le logement social en france il a
également déclaré qu'il fallait agir
pour redonner un avenir à l'opie voie et
qu'il allait s'y employer plusieurs
opposants dont des représentants des
locataires ou du personnel s'inquiète
néanmoins du projet annoncé de pierre
bédier soutenue par de nombreux élus de
droite il avait évoqué le projet de
démembrer l'opievoy pour créer trois
offices départementaux
et l'été ap les temps d'activités
périscolaires ce sont des moments après
l'école où les enfants sont encadrés par
des animateurs du sport à l'art en
passant par l'informatique l'été ap sont
mises en place et proposé par les
communes qui sont libres de leur choix
on tient d'activité demandant des
compétences techniques les animateurs
reçoivent des formations
mélanie poquet a suivi l'une d'entre
elles est en cours regardez les enfants
sont à l'école
les animateurs aussi ils sont là pour
découvrir le monde de la radio et le
proposer en activité aux élèves des
écoles primaires de la commune
nos animateurs sont formés par canopée
donc je rappelle que canopée et donc un
organisme qui dépend de l'éducation
nationale spécialisée dans la formation
pour les enseignants on a d'ailleurs
signé une convention avec eux et donc
l'un il
ils forment nos animateurs plus
spécifiquement ce matin sur le sur la
création d'une web radio savoir rédiger
un texte faire un montage mais aussi
installer le matériel technique leur
formation se passe sur 40 heures
j'ai un passé dans la radio donc je
retourne un peu aux sources et ça me
fait plusieurs du coup de pouvoir plus
tard le partager avec les enfants sur
les 170 animateurs présentent sur la
commune d'elancourt vin se consacre t ap
autour du numérique
il s'associe aux enseignants volontaires
ils peuvent s'exprimer
ils travaillent sur leurs expressions et
puis en même temps on va faire ça sur
sur un plan ludique les activités de
webradios commenceront après les
vacances de la toussaint
mercredi dernier la vie de bonnel dans
les yvelines avec les 78 réfugiés
syriens et irakiens
en attendant de leur trouver un logement
définitif ils sont accueillis placé au
monastère désoriente les associations
ont dû organiser l'accueil de ces hommes
de ces femmes et de ces enfants dans un
délai très court et il sent rien que ces
hommes et femmes sont arrivés sans rien
d'autre que par toi juste leurs
vêtements qu'ils portaient sur eux le
maire de la ville a donc lancé un appel
aux dons samedi dernier reportage de
william l vêtements couvertures produits
de toilette et jouer c'est littéralement
une montagne de dons qui a rempli la
salle communale samedi dernier à bonnel
les affaires presque tout trier ont déjà
rejoint le monastère où sont abrités les
réfugiés à vie mercredi dernier samedi
nous avons été surpris mais très très
surpris parce qu'à 9 heures les gens
faisaient la queue devant la salle des
fêtes et j'oserais dire que ça a été
ininterrompue jusqu'à 17 heures et le
soir en fait on ne pouvait quasiment
plus faut marcher dans la salle il y
avait d'énormes tas tout autour de la
salle polyvalente
donc ce sont plusieurs dizaines de
mètres cubes de tout ça curieux étaient
réunis donc je voudrais dire beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus que ce que nous
imaginions les organisateurs pas assez
nombreux pour recueillir et trier les
affaires ont été un peu dépassée au
début mais cet élan de générosité n'a
pas été seulement matériel ces gens là
étaient arrivés en premier 70 mais ça va
possible avec tout ce qui se passe là
vous allez être complètement débordé
donc en reste avec vous et donc c'est à
partir de là que s'est instaurée en fait
y avait plus du tout les son planning de
dire de telle heure à telle heure
sent-elle c'était tout il y avait au
moins dix quinze personnes en permanence
qui accueillait qui rangeait qui
classait qui mettait un des cartons dans
des sacs
quand nous avons dit qu'il y avait trois
enfants je crois que ces enfants là ont
des noëls jusqu'à la fin de leur vie
parce qu'en fait on a eu deux mètres
cubes de cadeaux de cadeaux de jouets
les réfugiés qui ont assisté à l'arrivée
de la collecte sont heureux de ce
soutien qu'ils reçoivent comme un
premier pas vers eux de la part des
habitants des zones à tignes mais c'est
un événement que rien tout ce dont nous
avons besoin est là est super je
remercie toutes les personnes qui sont
venues ici pour voter on retrace les
demandes d'asile de
78 réfugiés sont actuellement en train
d'être enregistré leur séjour au
monastère est prévu pour trois semaines
encore
il devrait ensuite être déplacé dans des
logements plus pérenne et l'association
habitat et humanisme lance un appel pour
l'accueil des réfugiés syriens et
irakiens elle recherche de façon urgente
trois volontaires entre 18 et 25 ans
pour une mission de service civique de
six mois à bonal pour plus
d'informations n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet
www.habitationdurable.com point org
pardon je rappelle que la question des
réfugiés et de leur accueil c'est le
thème du 7-8 société de ce soit
représentée par nouri noureddine agne
juste après l'édition de ce journal et
nous restons sur le thème de la
solidarité avec l'association
solidarités nouvelles face au chômage je
vous le disais en titre elle fête cette
année ses 30 ans d'existence pour en
parler avec nous en plateau il delpech
et hélène cazalis alors pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas solidarité face au
chômage le rôle de l'association est
avant tout d'accompagner les personnes
en recherche d'emploi de façon concrète
me semble-t-il tout à fait neutre
accompagne notre spécificité c'est un
accompagnement sur mesure des personnes
en recherche d'emploi
on sait aujourd'hui à quel point le
chômage fait des dégâts à la fois au
niveau collectif au niveau de la société
mais aussi au niveau individuel donc
notre action vise à redonner confiance à
des personnes qui ont perdu leur travail
à les aider à se reconstruire
professionnellement on a un principe qui
est très simple chaque chercheur
d'emploi qui nous contactent et mis en
relation avec un binôme de bénévoles
pour un accompagnement au rythme qui lui
convient et surtout aussi longtemps
qu'il en a besoin et de façon très
concrète comment cela se manifeste alors
nous nous travaillons nous dans la ligne
de snc puisqu'en fin de compte et c'est
c'est quand même 136 groupe et saint
quentin est un des 136 groupe et sur
saint quentin en yvelines le groupe
s'est créé en lui 992
d'abord ça qu'un groupe moyens gens
viennent vous les gens viennent vous
voir et vous accompagnez automatiquement
comment ça se passerait alors on
accompagne les gens qui peuvent être
accompagnés c'est à dire qu'il faut que
les gens sont soit en état de travailler
c'est la seule condition que nous posons
tout le reste
nous gérons ces trois heures par semaine
alors c'est lui dire elle avoue à la
volonté de l'accompagner c'est à dire
que si la compagnie veut nous voir
souvent on le voit souvent une fois par
semaine un réseau d'une heure et demie
deux heures trois heures petit à petit
au cours de l'accompagnement ça peut
être beaucoup plus éloignés et c'est de
l'accompagner qui nous viennent dans la
dans les duels le planning des rendez
vous nous nous devons toujours être à
son écoute
c'est d'accompagner a besoin entre deux
accompagnements d'un conseil où nous dit
par exemple j'ai raté mon entretien
d'embauché
qu'est-ce que je peux faire il faut
toujours être là pour lui servir un peu
de béquilles ce sont des bénévoles
justement qui s'occupe de cet
accompagnement en valent en 30 ans
d'existence vous avez la situation
évolue et vous apportez peut-être
d'autres vagues d'autres actions assez
personnellement
alors c'est vrai qu'en trente ans le
chômage s'est banalisé aujourd'hui ils
touchent tout le monde
l'ouvrier comme le cadre les hommes
comme les femmes quel que soit leur
niveau de deux diplômes les jeunes comme
les seniors donc effectivement ça c'est
un changement important le chômage aussi
a tendance à s'allonger
on est passé une durée moyenne de 14
mois donc on se rend compte à quel point
aujourd'hui l'accompagnement est utile
et nécessaire et on a aussi un
dispositif de création d'emplois pour
des personnes qui sont qui cherche un
emploi depuis longtemps
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle des emplois
solidaires et ont créé ces emplois d'une
durée moyenne d'un an dans des
structures de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et c'est un dispositif qui est
financée par des dons puisque notre
association ne reçoit pas de subventions
publiques
et justement pour cette photo est ce que
vous mettez en avant est ce qu'il va
passer c'est justement une pièce de
théâtre qui va être
au théâtre de versailles montansier donc
justement cette pièce date s'appelle un
emploi nommé désir alors la pièce
retrace le cheminement social et
psychologique d'une femme de 50 ans
licenciée du jour en moins après 15
années passées dans la même entreprise
voici ses impressions avec sa famille et
ses amis je vous propose de regarder un
extrait on le regarde tout de suite en
fait tout a commencé le jour où mon chef
m'a convoqué dans son bureau
ah ben voilà vous allez jouer mon chef
moi oui parce qu'il est comme vous un
peu coincé là un peu merci beaucoup
ces gens à prendre de la hauteur voyez
ce jeudi oui je vois tout à fait et
alors ce jour là il n'y arrivait pas à
finir ses phrases vous avez pas des
lunettes tu vois là ça va mieux me leur
présenter la voilà il avait des lunettes
comme pour se cacher derrière alors la
pièce se joue le jeudi 17 septembre au
théâtre de montansier à versailles à
20h30
elle affiche déjà complet pourquoi est
venue cette idée d'une d'une pièce de
théâtre justement pour parler du chômage
alors pour marquer notre trentième
anniversaire on avait envie de lutter
contre les idées reçues les stéréotypes
négatifs qui circulent encore trop
souvent sur le chômage et sur les
chômeurs
nous les gens qui viennent nous voir
c'est des gens qui se battent au
quotidien pour retrouver un emploi et
c'est ce quotidien difficile qu'on avait
envie de montrer avec cette pièce de
théâtre est ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que l'auteur de la pièce christian
poissonneau a fait un véritable travail
d'immersion
il a rencontré des gens au chômage qui
lui ont raconté leurs peurs leurs
parcours et il s'en est vraiment inspiré
pour écrire les textes
donc ça donne un résultat qui est très
percutant avec un spectacle qui
s'inspire du vécu il ya aussi beaucoup
d'interactivité dans cette pièce
les spectateurs sont invités à
s'exprimer sur ce qu'ils sont en train
de voir
et les comédiens rejoue les scènes à
partir des réactions des spectateurs
donc voilà ça donne un résultat avec
beaucoup d'humour et souvent on arrive
en fin de spectacle et on est assez
surpris d'avoir pris
vraiment autant de plaisir à regarder un
spectacle sur un sujet qui n'est quand
même pas évident au départ
il dépêche vous qui avez vu la pièce
qu'on sait c'est une bonne façon de
parler que quelques répétitions penser
que c'est une bonne façon d'aborder le
thème du chômage par le théâtre oui oui
parce que windows ont fini par donner
une image un peu plus positif du nos
vendeurs d'emploi parce que les gens se
rendent compte que derrière le demandeur
d'emploi c'est pas simplement une série
de clichés qu'on voit est la pièce la
pièce évoque également que le chômage
chez cette femme d'une cinquantaine
d'années chez sa fille qui est plus
jeune
vraiment l'association s'adresse à tous
l'association s'adresse à tous les
cibles oui pratiquement toutes les
cibles bon après ses deux futurs
accompagné qui va choisir de cheminée un
moment avec nous ou qui va dire non
c'est pas ça que cherche une qu'un trou
la main ou alors je n'ai pas besoin
qu'on leur apprennent des choses que je
connais voilà nous on est toujours vrai
après la compagnie choisie au coeur nous
le le le coeur de l'action s'est
accompagnée et séduit qui éventuellement
à un moment ou un autre peu dirais pas
ça y est maintenant votre accompagnement
et déterminé gens c'est assez j'ai plus
envie de travailler avec vous et si on
les fabrique des mois qu'ils sont les
bénévoles qui accompagnent justement ces
personnes y sont deux mondes qui
viennent vous voir sortir un petit peu
ces sont des entrepreneurs se sont dit
oui oui et non parce que on sait très
bien qu'à un moment ou un autre c'est
comme tout il faut que ça se finisse
alors ça se finit bien c'est à dire que
là c'est quand à personnes retrouvent un
emploi
ça se finit moins bien c'est quand on
commence à mettre en place des des
systèmes d' aides à l'emploi et tout ça
et ça peut se finir mal parce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui claquent apporte fâché en
disant vous m'avez fait d'armes montant
pourrait prêter justement des bénévoles
oui alors voilà justement ce que je
voulais dire c'est que chaque citoyen
peut devenir bénévole on part du
principe que tout le monde peut
s'engager en ayant en moyenne une heure
de son temps à donner aux chercheurs
d'emploi donc une heure de son temps
suffit ensuite l'association propose un
programme de format
lyon qui permet d'acquérir justement les
bases de l'accompagnement donc c'est
vraiment ouvert à tout le monde on a
autant d'actifs que de retraités à peu
près autant d'hommes que de femmes et
toutes les situations professionnelles
sont représentées parmi nos bénévoles
voilà on a un réseau de 2000 personnes
aujourd'hui en france qui sont sur le
terrain et évidemment l'association se
développe alors je vais avec le avec le
d'alimentation de la taille de
l'agglomération de signes content du
lean et scène ses 50 ans levin recrutera
beaucoup d'accompagnateur je vous
propose de regarder un second extrait de
la pièce de théâtre qui se joue donc
justement jeudi 17 septembre au théâtre
de montpensier à versailles pour vous
donner un petit peu envie de la voir
ça fait un an que j'ai terminé mes
études aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire
de ma remise des diplômes
pendant un an chez j'ai envoyé des
milliers de cv des milliers de lettres
de motivation tu allais à des dizaines
d'entretiens à chaque fois des échecs au
désolé mademoiselle mais vous êtes trop
blonde trop jeune trop diplômés pas à
ses diplômés alors nous on vous aurez
bien prises le problème si vous étiez 2
ou short list est l'autre c'était la
nièce de la petite cousine du président
alors vous comprenez et voilà donc la
pièce joue le 17 septembre des montants
sied malheureusement aller elle est
complète parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
succès mais peut-être va dans d'autres
communes ou d'entre eux ville du 78 vous
pouvez aller la voir
merci à vous d'être venu sur notre
plateau justin un dernier événement qui
va bientôt arriver c'est la soirée
agissons ensemble pour l'emploi au
château de buc le 15 octobre dont vous
allez participer justement à cette aide
à dissiper
voilà participer c'est très intéressant
et pour les personnes que nous
accompagnons ça va être l'occasion de
rencontrer des chefs d'entreprise et
pourquoi pas créer d'emploi qui leur
manque
eh bien nous suivrons cette actualité
oui vous avez téléchargé avait juste
quelque chose à rajouter pour justement
consulter le programme des prochains
événements on peut aller sur le site
dédié qui s'appelle snc point asso.fr
slash 30 ans et là vous avez toute la
liste des événements et la possibilité
de vous inscrire et bien voila merci
beaucoup toutes les informations sont
deux
et on continue avec les communes les
communes qui se mobilisent le samedi 9
septembre un appel est lancé par
l'association des maires de france qui
appelle à la mobilisation
en cause la décision de l'état de
réduire de 30% les dotations aux
communes et intercommunalités à saint
cyr l'école la mairie a même préparé un
cercueil symbolique le maire bernard
destin se mobilisent non sans humour il
donne rendez vous à ses concitoyens le
samedi 19 septembre à 9h30 pour un éloge
funèbre un dépôt des symboles de
délégation et signature du registre de
condoléances tout cela est symbolique
bien sûr pour plus d'informations rendez
vous sur le site www.frdj.ca orgueil et
comme chaque mardi nous parlons à
présent politique
avec vous ils frisent bonsoir ce soir il
est question du modem
bonsoir florane bonsoir à vos invités
également on y reviendra sur cette
question des dotations effectivement
dans le journal de demain parce que
c'est inquiète beaucoup les communes on
l'a vu le maire de saint cyr l'école
s'en amuse un petit peu mais ça reste un
sujet de préoccupation sérieuse là on va
parler du modem des régionales à présent
le modem qui vit un drôle de mois de
septembre la formation de françois
bayrou est elle en campagne ou non pour
ces régionales en île de france lui d y
est vous le savez s'est rallié aux
républicains avant même le premier tour
mais pour le moment pas d'accord avec le
modem sur une liste commune les chefs de
file à savoir marielle de sarnez yann
wehrling continuent donc leur tour du
département pour présenter un avant
projet qui pourrait bien devenir
définitif
si aucune entente n'est possible avec
valérie pécresse le modem ira devant les
électeurs mais seul c'est ce que nous
dit bruno myle yens le président du
modem dans le département forcément qui
à risque de toute façon on sait très
bien que si on y va on y va pour faire
entre 8 et 12%
voilà on va être car là dessus c'est
aussi une manière de nous montrer aussi
peut-être parce qu'il ya des gens qui
travaillent formidablement bien dans ce
mouvement notamment région ile de france
c'est plus difficile pour eux d'exister
parce qu'il ya des cadors des autres
partis on va être clair et des gens qui
sont en politique depuis très longtemps
mais il ya quand même des gens qui
travaillent très très bien chez nous et
qui ont porté notamment au niveau du
projet du modem parce que notre projet
quand même existe pour les régionales on
s'est préparé des choses très
intéressantes parce que le modem existe
encore aujourd'hui
bah écoutez on est oui on existe encore
la preuve c'est qu'on est dans les
discussions si on n'était pas en
discussion pourrait dire ça y est on est
mort on n'existe plus alors ce qui
coince c'est pas tellement le programme
c'est plutôt les places pour ces listes
sur les élections
aux régionales par dans d'autres termes
qui sera éligible ou pas c'est ça qui
préoccupent les candidats aujourd'hui
et puis ce n'est un secret pour personne
nicolas sarkozy n'a toujours pas digéré
l'appel à voter françois hollande est
lancée par françois bayrou lors de la
dernière présidentielle mais le modem
qui présente seule une liste pour les
régionales est ce que c'est une bonne
idée
est ce qu'une alliance ne serait pas
plutôt profitable pour l'avenir de cette
formation voici ce qu'en pense une
partie des électeurs que nous avons
rencontrés parce que vous pensez que le
modem doit s'allier aux républicains
pour ces élections
peut-être je sais pas peut-être pas oui
oui
autrement l'union fait la force comme on
dit autrement il sombre sur mal barré
donc moi je pense pas parce qu'il vaut
mieux qu'ils restent indépendants oui il
se sera une grande force c'est quelque
chose d'intelligent
non ça je vois que les républicains et
un rejet total enfin une bonne partie
qui a rejet de l'immigration et le modem
et plus et plus modérée là dessus je
suis plus d'accord avec eux ah bah oui
parce que bon je pense que madame est
plus à droite qu'à gauche
un derniers bruits de couloir concernant
ces régionales il se dit que si l'accord
n'arrivait pas à se faire avec les
républicains donc le modem irait seul et
ce serait françois bayrou qui pourraient
s'impliquer personnellement en ile de
france
une fois qu'il en soit le modem continue
ses rencontres dans les yvelines le
modem yvelines qui proposent par exemple
le 17 septembre un petit déjeuner sur le
thème du régime social des indépendants
le rsi c'est ce système qui gère la
protection sociale obligatoire de plus
de cinq millions et demi de chefs
d'entreprise et de leurs ayants droit le
rendez-vous va se passer à poissy
écouter une nouvelle fois bruno milliers
on va encore rencontrer des
entrepreneurs pour parler du rsi ça
tombe bien c'est un député ps qui rend
son rapport la le 15 septembre il me
semble donc deux jours après nous on
aura analysé ces conclusions on aura
amené quelques précisions sur ce qu'on
pense du rsi ça se fera en présence du
président
rsi d'île de france ouest donc quand
même il vient il vient pour prendre des
coups entre guillemets on veut pas
qu'ils prennent deux coups un bon jeu
surtout qu' un dialogue qui s'instaure
entre les entrepreneurs et les gens du
rsi pour qu'on voit si on peut se sortir
de cette espèce de magma
incompréhensible par beaucoup alors que
peut-être il ya des raisons pour
lesquelles s'est tendue et qu'il faut
essayer de les résoudre
merci wilfried est toujours en politique
c'est le retour du politique ce premier
numéro de la seconde saison deuxième
saison du café politique cette fois ci
avec la mère des clayes-sous-bois la
centriste véronique côté millard
toujours au bistrot du théâtre à
montigny le bretonneux une demi-heure
pour mieux connaître les élus parler de
quelques-uns des dossiers chauds du
moment nous parlons donc avec véronique
côté millard des clayes-sous-bois de la
nouvelle intercommunalité de saint
quentin en yvelines qui rentre en
vigueur le 1er janvier et puis on
parlera également de la question des
migrants et de l'accueil des migrants
dans sa commune première diffusion
samedi dimanche le week-end 14h 19h 30
merci wilfried et de la politique nous
passons maintenant aux sports tout autre
sujet le sport qui était à l'honneur ce
week-end à lille de loisirs a participé
pour la sixième année consécutive à
sentez vous sport au programme
découverte de différentes activités
sportives comme la foule dance le speed
ball mais cette année l'événement a
fusionné avec le rallye découverte pour
tous l'événement vise à rapprocher
valides et personnes en situation de
handicap ou de mobilité réduite toujours
sur le thème du sport des images a signé
william elle se déplacer en fauteuil
roulant une activité très physique pour
ses enfants
à l'occasion de son thé vous sports il
participe au rallye découverte et
s'essaye aux difficultés que rencontrent
les personnes en situation de mobilité
réduite chaque jour c'est la première
fois que j'essaye et je trouve quand
même que c'est difficile pour eux enfin
je pense que c'est difficile et ça fait
beaucoup travailler les bras
je trouve ça super bien de pouvoir vivre
ce que vivent tous les jours
à l'origine de cette initiative du
rallye découverte l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin liste de
loisirs et surtout l'association
escapade liberté et mobilité
son but développer l'accessibilité des
personnes handicapées et âgées
aux loisirs comme avec ce module évasion
en kayak pour fauteuil roulant
l'association souhaite aussi créer un
échange et de la mixité autour de ce
thème
le propos il s'adresse à toutes les
personnes qui sont autour de nous parce
que forcément on peut devenir dans une
situation invalidante
on a forcément des proches des enfants
des grands parents etc
donc c'est vraiment une thématique qui
nous concerne tous
escapade liberté et mobilité vrai
également pour les personnes âgées
elle met en avant une pratique sportive
adaptée à sa condition et costumes santé
c'était aussi l'objectif historique tome
sentez vous sport pour fusionner avec
avec le lm bafé vraiment que c'est
vraiment un événement pour tous c'est à
dire que des personnes en situation de
handicap peuvent pratiquer aussi bien
des activités vont à spécifique pour
elle mais aussi d'autres activités comme
comme je ne sais pas le tir carabine
laser par exemple et malgré la pluie
l'événement a su fédérer
plus d'une centaine de personnes sont à
l'école jean de loisy et nous restons
sur les événements de ce week-end samedi
dernier à voisins le bretonneux se
tenait le traditionnel forum des
associations plus d'une centaine
d'associations étaient présentes pour
accueillir les curieux les visiteurs de
la journée
c'était l'occasion pour les vies sinois
de découvrir et de s'inscrire à de
nouvelles activités sport culture
sociale ou même moisir comme le club de
poker
reportage de william l
peinture sculpture ou sport c'était
l'occasion de choisir son activité
samedi à voisins le bretonneux aux
fourneaux des associations découvrir et
se renseigner pour certains bien
directement s'inscrire au que le
convoité pour d'autres j'aime bien les
jeux de cartes donc je voulais
m'inscrire
dans un club pour faire rage pour atarot
belote poker qui sera donc ce qui est un
peu de poker ici en plus ça tombe bien
les détecte que je connais les y
inscrire les quatre ou cinq ans déjà
au lieu de jouer sur internet c'est bien
mais on est toujours tout seul que là
c'est plutôt avec des adhérents et ça
fait plaisir de changer d' apprendre le
poker un jeu qui a connu ses heures de
gloire il ya quelques années a perdu
aujourd'hui un peu de la ferveur
populaire qui suscitent tout cet
engouement commence à s'éteindre un peu
c'est il ya quelques années ça qui a eu
la vague d'inscriptions avec patrick
bruel qui passe à la télé et là
maintenant ça commence à passer donc un
petit peu moins d'inscriptions qu'avant
srec avant de tourner autour de 150
adhérents maintenant on est plutôt
autour de 100 125 adhérents annuelle
aujourd'hui pas besoin de bluffer avec
les visiteurs venus se renseigner
cent neuf associations étaient présentes
sur cette journée qui reste pour elle un
très bon moyen de se faire coudre et le
club d'oenologie de
voisins-le-bretonneux étaient aussi
présents à ce forum on écoute pascal
pieds-noirs son président qui nous parle
de son succès c'est une affaire de
groupe 1 puisque voilà c'est pas un
titre personnel c'est vraiment un
collectif qui travaillent chaque
mercredi pour pour développer ses
connaissances et ses sensibilités sur le
groupe des premières années il y avait
une majorité de femmes donc pourquoi
pensez que c'est c'est très masculin non
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
gastronomie d' accompagnement de plats
et de 20 au sein des cours et c'est une
approche et une passion que l'on partage
ensemble
souvent on dit oui mais
le no logis ça coûte cher la coupe bien
moins cher qu'un ado à bateaux et la
somme effectivement puisque on va
chercher quelques signatures de grands
vignerons certes mais la laddh la somme
est partagé par 110 donc voilà fait tout
à fait accessible et je le rappelle le
club de voisin détenteur de la coupe de
france 2014 il remettra d'ailleurs son
titre en jeu ce week-end à montpellier
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous donne rendez
vous demain à 18 heures pour une
nouvelle édition du journal en direct
tout de suite resté sur tv fils pour le
7-8 société il sera question des
réfugiés avec noureddine année mais je
vous souhaite une très bonne sera sur
tf1